MINUTE NOW SO WE'LL WAIT UNTIL
THAT HOPEFULLY HAPPENS IF NOT
WE'LL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND TO IF THAT HAPPENS WE'LL
HEAR -- OF THE ONLY ITEM THAT WE
HAVE -- ON ITEMS TO BE HEARD
WITH THIS.
LAUNCH INTO THAT.
BUT LET'S GIVE IT A MINUTE AND
SEE IF -- SEE IF WE HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP
.
OKAY WELL WHY DON'T WE MOVE --
TO ITEMS TO BE HEARD WELL --
BEGIN OUR MEETING THIS MORNING.
WITH A ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CHECK THAT.
HE KNEW IT HAPPENED AS SOON AS I
STARTED TALKING -- SO WE'LL TAKE
A TAKE ROLE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND MOVE IN ORIGIN [inaudible]
BLOOM.
HERE FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE FINAL
MEETING OF ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER.
THREE IT'S A IT'S BEEN A GOOD
YEAR AND IT -- I WANNA THANK.
ALL OF YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
OUR HEARINGS BY PARTICULARLY
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND
THE STAFF THAT WORKS OUT REALLY
HARD -- TO INFORMANT ADVISED US
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR ON
THE MANY COMPLICATED ISSUES THAT
WEEK -- SEE BEFORE US HERE AND
AND SUB THREE SO -- THANK THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE HARD WORK THAT
YOU.
HAVE DONE UP UNTIL NOW AND I
KNOW OF COURSE -- ONCE WE FINISH
OUR WORK -- HERE THIS MORNING
YOU'VE GOT A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
ON ON THE BUDGET TO GETTING US
THROUGH TO A WHAT I'M SURE WILL
BE ANOTHER -- ON TIME FINISH --
OR BEFORE JUNE FIFTEENTH SO WITH
THAT -- WE WILL -- CALL THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR I HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON THAT FIRST ON ISSUE
NUMBER. TWO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION REFERENCES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE -- BUT THAT
SHOULD BE CORRECTED TO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WHEN -- WE
ENTERTAIN A OF A VOTE ON THAT --
WILL REFERENCE SAID THAT THAT
CHANGE IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION -- BUT BEFORE I
ASK FOR A MOTION ON THAT --
ISSUE I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE --
UP UP GEN BASICALLY APPROVING
THE ITEM TODAY WITH THE THAT --
WITH THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BUT I REMAIN CONCERNED WITH THE
LONG TERM HEALTH OF THE TIMBER
RIGHT.
REGULATION THE FORCED
RESTORATION FUND AN ANNUAL
REPORT IS REQUIRED EACH YEAR ON
JANUARY TENTH.
THAT REPORT WOULD PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE REVIEW APPROVAL AND
INSPECTION OF TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS AND ASSOCIATED PERMITS.
THE NUMBER OF TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS -- THE ACREAGE THAT'S
COVERED BY THE PLANS THE COST OF
OTHER FORESTRY RELATED
ACTIVITIES UNDERTAKEN IN A
SUMMARY OF THE PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS IDENTIFIED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AS PART OF THEIR ONGOING REVIEW
OF THE TIMBER HARVEST PROCESS --
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE DATA AND
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVEMENT NEEDS.
OF THE LAST THREE YEARS THE THE
RUB THE THE LAST REPORT THAT WAS
SUBMITTED WAS IN -- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORTS ARE NOW VERY PASSED TO
AND SO I JUST WANT -- TO
TELEGRAPHER -- CONCERN HERE AND
HOPE THAT THE RESOURCES AGENCY
IS PUT ON NOTICE THAT -- AT THIS
COMMITTEE EXPECTS THIS OF MIDDLE
OF THE REPORT TO IN THE VERY
NEAR TERM.
ALL OF THESE REPORTS.
OF ONE ISSUE NUMBER -- SEVEN THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER ITEMS -- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK YOU ALL KNOW IS.
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART I'VE
WORKED ON FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
I THINK THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
GENERALLY SHARES A CONCERN --
ABOUT THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
IS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY --
AND SOME PARTS OF OUR STATE.
RESIDENTS ARE A LIVING IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN IT RELATES TO
WATER -- THAT IS MUCH LIKE
DEVELOPING NATIONS THERE ARE IN
FACT.
OVER THREE HUNDRED ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND VIRTUALLY EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA CONTAINS A SOME
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND
RESIDENTS.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY -- AN
ESTIMATED ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
AND THEREFORE RELY ON PURCHASING
WATER AND HAULING IT INTO THEIR
HOMES -- THAT'S JUST --
UNFATHOMABLE A IN THIS DAY AND
AGE AND SO WE NEED A SUSTAINABLE
FRAMEWORK TO PERMANENTLY SOLVE
THE CRISIS.
THERE ARE SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE
MEASURES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER CONSIDERATION I AM THE
AUTHOR OF ONE OF THEM -- BUT AS
WEIRD THE DIFFERING QUé --
OTHER CREATION OF A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM -- TO THE POLICY PROCESS
TO ALLOW THOSE BILLS TO MOVE
FORWARD -- BUT I DO WANT TO
REITERATE MY OF A CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE NOT YET RESOLVED THIS
ISSUE AND AND WE MUST.
WE HAVE THREE BUDGET REQUEST
REGARDING WILDFIRES IN UTILITIES
THAT WILL TAKE ACTIONS ON THAT
REFLECT OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
APPROVING FUNDING FOR NEW
ACTIVITIES ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
FOR THE DMV WE ADOPT A MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT PLAN THAT
ENSURES THE FUND BALANCE REMAINS
HEALTHY AND IS ABLE TO FUND OUR
PRIORITIES. FOR THE DMV BUDGET
REQUEST FOR FUNDING TO IMPROVE
ITS OVERALL OPERATIONS WE TAKE
ACTIONS THAT WILL HOLD THE DMV
ACCOUNTABLE FOR APPROVING A FOR
IMPROVING ITS PERFORMANCE.
AND FINALLY FOR CAP AND TRADE WE
ARE ADOPTING AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
THAT REFLECTS OUR HIGH LEVEL
PRIORITIES IT DOESN'T GET INTO
QUITE THE DETAIL THAT -- WE'RE
ALL USED -- TO FROM PASS BUDGETS
BUT I THINK THIS IS GOING TO
ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON THE HIGH
LEVEL PRIORITIES.
AND THE OF COURSE SO WILL
CONTINUE WITHIN THOSE HIGH LEVEL
PRIORITIES TO CONSIDER ALL THE
NUANCES IN THE PROGRAMS -- THAT
MANY OF YOU HAVE ADVOCATED OVER
THE OVER THE THE YEARS.
AS A TECHNICAL ISSUE FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUE TWENTY TWO WE'RE
GOING TO MODIFY THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IN THE AGENDA.
AND APPROVE CASH FUNDING FOR THE
CHP CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAMS FOR
EL CENTRO AND SAN BERNARDINO.
AND REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR THOSE TWO PROJECTS --
AND WE WILL APPROVE THE
REVERSION OF THE FUNDING FOR THE
HAYWARD PROJECT AND REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
FINANCE THE COST OF THIS PROJECT.
ON UP WITH THAT IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE.
MS GARCIA DID YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND IF ANY OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADD SOME COMMENTS --
PLEASE LET ME KNOW MISSY ELLIOTT
THANK YOU -- CHAIR -- I WILL BE
VOTING FOR ITEM A BUT I I DID
JUST WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
STATEMENT THAT I HOPE.
IN THE FUTURE WE START LOOKING
AT THESE LOANS -- FOR THE EXACT
CLEAN UP AND WE START THINKING
ABOUT THE MATH ONE TIME
APPROPRIATIONS -- WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT FLUSH WITH CASH AT
THIS TIME -- BUT IN ADDITION TO
THESE LOANS SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
IN THE FUTURE SINCE WE HAVE A
BATTERY FEE FUND.
WILL BE ABLE TO PAY FOR THE
CLEANUP THROUGH THERE AND SO
JUST A I HOPE THAT WE START
CONSIDERING THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- I
MAILED I KNOW THE COMMITMENT IN
THIS HOUSE BUT TO SAY THAT TO
EVERYONE ELSE'S NAME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE ALL
RIGHT THEN -- IS THERE A MOTION
TO APPROVE.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
THREE A AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE
TO LET THEM NOT I'M NOT.
THE IT'S LONGER THAN THAT BUT I
WANT TO PAUSE AND SAY THAT --
AGAIN -- ISSUE TOO WHICH IS THAT
WITHIN -- ISSUE ONE THROUGH --
THREE THAT IS GOING TO BE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE INSTEAD OF
PROVISIONAL.
OF TWO ISSUES ONE THROUGH
356-831-0122 FIFTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN FOR TWENTY ONE DO I
HEAR MOTION.
THANK YOU BLOOM I FONG
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
AND TO DO I HEAR A MOTION TO
APPROVE ISSUES SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY THROUGH. TWO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU AND FINALLY IS THERE
AND A MOTION TO APPROVE ISSUES
FOR SEVEN AND ELEVEN BLOOM.
HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE
ITEM TO BE HEARD -- CONSERVATION
GENOMICS THAT'S ISSUE ONE AND I
BELIEVE -- DR MARKEL DOES HERE
[inaudible]
TOO PRESENT [inaudible]
THE STATE.
WE SO LONG EVERYONE THANK YOU.
TURN TAKE IT PERSONALLY DR GOLD.
I DON'T EVEN THIRDTIME YEAH HI
I'M NOT WHY WOULD YOU
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK ABOUT RESEARCH TO CONSERVE
CALIFORNIA'S UNPARALLELED
NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND WHILE I FOR A CHANGING
FUTURE IN THE FACE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS.
THIS MONTH -- THE UNITED NATIONS
RELEASED THE SUMMARY FINDINGS OF
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE BY
DIVERSITY ASSESSMENT TODAY.
AND THESE FINDINGS WERE WENT FAR
BEYOND SOBERING.
AN ESTIMATED ONE MILLION ANIMAL
AND PLANT SPECIES ON THE VERGE
OF EXTINCTION.
AND THESE UNPARALLELED LOSSES.
I'M IN HUMAN HISTORY ARE DUE TO
HUMAN ACTIVITY ON A QUICKLY
WARMING CLIMATE HABITAT LOSS
POLLUTION AND MORE HAVE BEEN THE
CAUSE OF THOSE TRIED BOXES.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE OF THE
PLANET'S BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS
ONE OF THIRTY FIVE OF THEM.
YEAH UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED ENDANGERED
AND THREATENED SPECIES.
AN EVEN GREATER NUMBER OF
SPECIES HABITATS AND ECOSYSTEMS
ARE UNDER THE THREAT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HABITAT LAST LOSS AND
MORE.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A SCIENTIST ON
THE ON FOR YOU DON'T KNOW FROM
MY BACKGROUND ON I'M ASSOCIATE
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
SUSTAINABILITY ON AT UCLA.
ON AND I'M ALSO A FACULTY MEMBER
ON THE NEEDS TO BE ENVIRONMENT
SUSTAINABILITY.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY AS A
SCIENTIST TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
CONSERVATION BIOLOGY BIOLOGY
TOOLS THAT CAN BE USED TO BETTER.
MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S PRECIOUS BY
DIVERSITY.
THE FIELD OF CONSERVATION
GENOMICS ALLOW SCIENTISTS TO
IDENTIFY SPECIES AND POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO
HABITAT LOSS.
ENTER CLIMATE CHANGE
[inaudible]
THESE POPULATIONS THOSE
POPULATIONS WITH THE GREATEST
GENETIC VARIABILITY ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO ADAPT TO ADVERSE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS IN
THESE TOOLS ALLOW US TO IDENTIFY.
ON THOSE RESILIENT POPULATIONS.
TO DATE YOU SEE SCIENTISTS.
I WORKED ON APPROXIMATELY FORTY
SPECIES RANGING FROM OAKS TO
MIGRATING BIRDS TO FISH AND
REPTILES.
THIS INFORMATION IS CRITICAL TO
DETERMINE POSSIBLE LOCATIONS FOR
CITING RENEWABLE ENERGY.
FACILITIES SO THEY BECAUSE A
MINIMAL ENVIRONMENTAL HARM.
GENOMICS ALSO ENABLES US TO MAKE
FAR MORE EFFECTIVE WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT AND MITIGATION
DECISIONS.
THE CONSERVATION SONOMA TOOLS
ARE NOT ENOUGH TO RESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S BY DIVERSITY.
USE IN CONJUNCTION WITH CLIMATE
MODELING AND REMOTE SENSING THE
STATE CAN BUILD CLIMATE
RESILIENCE INTO OUR NATURAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
CONSERVANCY'S CAN PURCHASE LANCE
NOT BASED ON JUST THE STATE OF
THE LAND TODAY.
BUT ON PROJECTIONS OF WHAT THE
LAND WILL BE LIKE AT THE END OF
THE CENTURY.
ALL OF THESE FIELDS ARE
INSTRUMENTAL TO A MORE MODERN
APPROACH TO HAS OUR MANAGEMENT
FROM WILD FIRE AND FLOOD.
INTO A RESTAURANT RESTORATION
ECOLOGY APPROACH TO LIMIT ON
FUTURE DAMAGES.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER ON
SCIENTIFIC INNOVATION IN
CONSERVATION BIOLOGY IS NO
DIFFERENT.
ALL TEN UC'S HAVE RESEARCHERS
WORKING IN THE FIELDS I'VE
DESCRIBED.
AND WE STAND BY READY TO WORK
WITH STATE AGENCIES THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE CAPITAL.
ON THE STATE WIDE RESEARCH
EFFORT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ON THE SIDE.
THANK YOU MISTER TERRY SULLIVAN
SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY JUST IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSED A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CONSERVATION GENOMICS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION TO
IMPROVE A PROOF.
WHEN I DON'T THINK WE CAN
IMPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
MAYBE WE COULD?
THE TO APPROVE A DID WE HAVE A
MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLOOM.
HI.
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
SEN [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
DO ANNOUNCED THE RESULTS.
THE ITEM PASS ON A FIVE ONE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING GOD I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL AGAIN FOR A GREAT YEAR.
AND WE'RE ADJOURNED